- I could maybe try and do
something for you guys now.
- Yes.
- I want to see it.
(audience cheering)
Wait, so you just like
out of nowhere, like.
(audience cheering)
Okay, okay.
- Hey.
- Okay.
- What was your local mall?
- Local mall.
Hulen.
- Hulen.
- Hulen Mall.
- And what your favorite
like food at the food court?
- Local is like 40 minutes away.
- Yeah, yeah, I know how it works.
- A small town.
What, my food?
- Food court.
Who did you eat at the food court?
- I didn't eat at the mall.
I was poor, I just window shopped.
(laughing)
- What did you eat at the food court?
- Panda Express.
- Oh okay, okay, okay.
- Favorite dish?
- It was like orange chicken
- Yeah.
- You better believe it.
- Love their.
- Okay and now for both of you,
first CD that you ever got?
CDs or compact, don't worry about it.
- I was gonna say, probably
Boyz II Men Mowtownphilly.
- Love it and.
- Okay.
- Spice Girls.
- Nice.
(audience cheering)
What was the first one,
Spice Up Your Life?
- Spice world.
- Spice Up Your Life, Spice World?
- Spice World, you know what.
- We'll just say Spice Girls.
- We'll just
give me a, were you guys,
yeah, let's just do something like.
(beat boxing)
(percussive music)
- Oh my God.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- I hear it, I hear it, I hear it.
Now once upon a time, not long ago
before the Idol and the
Kelly Clarkson Show.
Yeah, my girl, what was she doing?
Going to the mall, yeah
it was called Hulen,
What's she there for,
she there a window shop
'cause she's oh so poor.
Oh yes, oh yes, my girl Vanessa
was over at the Panda Express
looking so good, yeah she finger licking,
go up to the counter
get the orange chicken.
What you do with me,
you see I'm Boyz II Men
listening to Motownphilly.
Oh, oh, so nice.
I'm on the mic and I'm
crazier than Scary Spice
and Ginger head bringer, I am the ringer.
I'll do it all day long,
that's right I never linger.
I'm here Mr. Indian so full of melanin.
I rock up the microphone that
came to spit without the pen.
But anyway, I think I'm done.
I'm broken and I'm beautiful.
That was my musical.
(audience cheering)
- That's actually crazy!
- Tick, tick boom.
- That is actually crazy!